GOP leader Kevin McCarthy telling Joe's
border Chief to either hit the bricks or
face impeachment
our country may never recover from
secretary mayorkas
dereliction of Duty if secretary
mayorkas does not resign
House Republicans will investigate every
order
every action
and every failure
will determine whether we can begin
impeachment inquiry McCarthy also has a
plan to finally get Democrats to go down
to the Border no longer will members
have to come down to the border to tour
we will hold our hearings at the border
so the Democrats can no longer hide from
the crisis they have created the White
House mouthpiece hitting back claiming
Republicans are playing politics and
that they have a plan
we've partnered with Mexico and
Guatemala to tackle the criminal
smuggling networks preying on immigrants
those efforts have already resulted in
thousands of arrests because of the work
that this president has done he bought
20 leaders together to collaborately
manage the immigration challenge
impacting the whole Western Hemisphere
and we're stopping Fentanyl before it
even makes it to the streets of the
United States so we have a plan we've
been putting that forward
McCarthy has no plan the Republican
party has no plan they do nothing except
do political stunts so Josh I want to
ask you a really important question uh
what are your plans for Thanksgiving uh
can you give me a ride to where we're
going you betcha well actually I can't
drive so I'll be in the backseat with
you all right so she says they have a
plan but I that doesn't sound like a
plan to me what do you think okay she
says we have a solution to this we set
it here the ways that we can deal with
this well you know what Kareem you got
the house you got the Senate you got the
oval what plan do you have you have no
plan it's more spin I always feel like
when this woman gets up to the to speak
to the public it's like a school teacher
who doesn't know the topic who's always
yelling at the students if they dare ask
a question but here's the here's the
real issue here she said we call
together these countries Mexico and
Guatemala and we are preventing fentanyl
from hitting the streets in the United
States are you stupid is that you're
really doing that not only are they not
doing it in this Western Hemisphere
conference they did not have at the
conference that she's talking about Cuba
Nicaragua Venezuela El Salvatore
Guatemala Honduras and the president of
Mexico so she can spin all she wants but
nothing they're doing is making a damn
bit of difference no it also the
fentanyl thing is impossible you can't
stop fentanyl at the border it's the
smallest drug on Earth you can put that
anywhere and kill 20 million people that
it's not like marijuana where you have
it's giant you know when it fentanyl it
can't be stopped but Jessica do you
think given the choice that mayorkas has
is he gonna go for the impeachment or
will he hit the bricks
I think he'll go for it really I guess
so if well you mean McCarthy or my orcas
mayor completely resigned before
no I don't think so I I
he said I'm not resigning and there are
a number of Democrats like Katie Hobbs
who's about to become the governor of
Arizona markelli senator from Arizona
Ruben galleo Congressman Henry Cuellar
are all basically saying the same thing
now which is that the Democrats do not
have a solid perspective on what's going
on and it's always interesting and gaio
and Cuellar I should say to be honest
they've been saying this for a couple
years now but you get this like a fresh
six months right after an election
before you have to start fundraising
again where people really speak their
mind right and they're talking about the
issues that matter to their voters and
they have this new mandate that they've
just been elected and it's very
interesting to me that Katie Hobbs and
Mark Kelly are using this moment to be
talking about immigration first and
foremost and what's going on at the
border now in terms of McCarthy holding
hearings down there I think that it will
be quite easy to paint that as a stunt
on the Democratic side of things but
this is a singularly unifying issue for
Republicans which they usually don't
find right everybody cares about this
one whether you're a trump supporter to
the most moderate Republican you think
that this is an issue that has been
completely mishandled so I think that it
is smart from that perspective but I
don't see my orcas resigning it is
crossing the party divide do you believe
that's a stunt going down to the Border
like Jessica says
I don't believe it's a stunt but I would
shift the messaging a little bit with
the Republicans
they've been running on safety for a
while and that hasn't worked sure some
of the Border towns you've been able to
split some of those seats you get some
of the Democrats that are on the city
councils that have changed their
position but on a national stage that
hasn't really won people over so you got
to change it to be about the illegal
migrants you got to take people to the
scene of the crime you got to take them
to Big Ben's second where you can smell
the rotten bodies and you don't know
where they are you smell them but you
don't know because of the journey that
they they've taken and they're they're
drenching because of the Texas heat you
got to take them to the local
communities where there's no food in the
pantries that the restaurants have run
out of food you got to take them to the
hotels where they've run out of rooms
there because they have showed all the
migrants there you have to paint the
picture of what these migrants go
through making this honestly they should
host one in the back of an 18-wheeler
stay there for three minutes and see how
I feel people stay there for hours hour
sometimes days you gotta show what these
migrants from a compassion that left is
really good about that when it comes to
compassion even though if it's misplaced
that time remember when AOC was crying
at the border correct I'll never forget
that moment take her to the real fences
yeah all right
they need to interview some of the young
girls that are raped along the journey
so it's not a stunt when you can take
them to different stages of the crime
because it is a crime this is a criminal
Enterprise and you got to show people
the destination and what it takes to get
to that destination yeah so the reason I
mean at least for me the reason for a
hearing is to talk about the whip right
I mean isn't that like the the I mean
majorcus you could almost I mean he's an
inept person right you could tell he's
inept but if but he threw all of his
employees under the bus he destroyed try
to I mean essentially destroyed these
agents lives by acting as though he
didn't know it wasn't a whip but he was
fold is that something that is worthy of
investigation that that he knew that it
was a lie when he said it yeah and the
vice president of the United States then
said it and castigated those uh border
agents on Horseback and compared it to
slavery when it was a lie and then the
president United States himself stood
behind the presidential steel and
repeated that lie about the whipping of
the migrants and to compare and contrast
that is the only time Biden and his
callous cronies got angry was when it
benefited them politically and they
stood up there and they lied about
border agents whipping Haitian migrants
but they have not gotten angry about
women being raped they have not gotten
angry about children drowning and people
suffocating to death in the back of a
tractor trailer and the cartels and the
human traffickers and the drug
traffickers prospering from this wide
open border and then tens of thousands
of people dying from fentanyl poisonings
every year they haven't shed one tear
about that but boy they sure did get
angry to Pedal a lie to discredit our
border agents all right Gutfeld destroys
tarloff in heated debate yes that's the
headline I can't wait my mom will send
it to me right away yes shoes being
thrown